invitation here and I just like to start
out by saying that I'm going to talk
mostly about new work in Sauber's but
I'm going to start out by covering some
published work in my house very quickly
but all of this is tied together with
the focus on interactions between motor
and auditory systems in the mouse were
particularly secondary motor cortical
interactions with primary auditory
cortex and in the bird work vocal
promoter regions that are important to
song patterning and their interactions
with higher-level
auditory areas of those projections for
learning so just maybe to set the stage
with speech mechanisms it's a
appreciator that there's a modular
organization that brennick has shown
time and again that productive versus
receptive aspects of speech are
localized to different parts of the
cortical mantle and particularly in the
left hemisphere and most individuals but
underlying those modules is a
bi-directional network of fibers
including the arcuate fasciculus which
conveys information both from the
auditory system to the frontal regions
of the brain and also we think from
motor regions of the brain of the
auditory cortex and so the things is
there a sizing option I have but I'll
talk about motor cortical modulation of
auditory cortical activity and then
motor on those lights
we'll talk about local timing mechanisms
great thank you okay so so there are
many many examples of how movement is
auditory processing but probably the
most compelling evidence is from
recordings made in vocalizing marmoset
from the primary auditory cortex of
these animals by Steven le Otteson Shao
Shang Wang that showed a vocalization
related suppression of auditory cortical
activity and in fact the timing of this
precedes the onset of vocalization
suggestive of a motor origin and this
this is this and other observations
including similar effects in human
speakers has led the idea that there's a
motor to auditory cortical interaction
but in fact the cellular and circuit
mechanisms of that interaction have have
remained fairly obscure so in the first
part of the talk what I want to cover is
looking at the circuitry that underlies
this movement related modulating
auditory cortex in a mouse model and
address these questions including the
the membrane potential signature of
movement in the auditory cortex the
cellular synaptic effectors of this
movement related modulation and the
sources of these signals or at least
some of those sources so using either
head fixed myosin on the left the wake
moving mice on the left or tethered but
otherwise unrestrained mice on the right
we made intracellular recordings from
auditory cortical neurons during rest
and movement the take-home is is that
membrane potential dynamics your current
clamp record from a from an excitatory
cell in the auditory cortex change in
pattern undergo a slight depolarization
and then decrease in variance that
precedes movement onset and persist for
some time after movement offset and when
we started these experiments we were
focused and recording and vocalizing
animals but we actually quickly
recognized that this kind of movement
related effect can be seen generically
that is at I any any evidence of
movement that we could find whether it
be locomotor or grooming sniffing paw
movements posturing all of these were
associated with changes in membrane
potential dynamics in conditions where
we had mailmouse investigating and
chasing after a female Mouse which was
the most reliable for inducing
vocalization we could see movement
related shifts and dynamics that
persisted during the vocal bow so who
seems to be a relatively general feature
of the Opera birthdays in the mouth said
it's a wide range of movements in the
speaker related suppression auditory
cortical activity group and others and
to localize this effect she's not a
university printer axises it's nice I
swear who the blazes seems very
processing in fact there's a confusing
reflex that engages the tensor to
enhance the PDS muscles so there must be
effects from from the periphery all the
way to the cortex and the question is
how much if it can be localized to the
cortex if any so using strategy to
selectively activate a lot of people
having terminals and not very cortex
president had a portable origin and by
recording and injecting current into the
cell wall Deanna posted her aggressive
movement moving we can see his shot
multi-electrode array recordings in
cortex and then hot genetically
identifying in turn on
breeding here and excitatory cell shown
in black we could chart the relative
asset and see an increase in inhibitory
cell activity the police needed and was
taught model to decrease an excitatory
cell action potential activity so this
is all suggestive of a feed poor or
inhibitory practice which interneuron
activity is repeated during movement to
shut through the post post synaptic
membrane you decided for yourself in
your auditory cortex respective sources
one major source that we identified
using retrograde tidal traces methods
it's a large population of cells in both
the superficial and deep layers of the
secondary motor cortex and and rate
tracing the viruses identified
terminations in auditory cortex
including close tab positions are
dependent positive cells again turning
to multi-electrode array employers
reporting now in the secondary motor
cortex we could see an increase in
action potential activity that preceded
any of the changes in action potential
or penetrating actually I haven't said
be reported in auditory cortex
consistent with the idea that actually
could be what source of drive to the
local image or a circuit that generates
these movement related effects and so to
look at this again it awake but resting
mice and be a selectively activated
these senators or cortical terminals you
see the rest like dynamics high
variability the light turns on there's a
signature but for all intents and
purposes what was life what we reported
her movement
it's a decreased variance and a slight
depolarization
at rest similarly if we probe during
either electrolytes on the tone of oak
responsiveness is detrimental during the
lights off based consistent with m2
being a source of movement related
activity that's driving this decrease in
aught occurs I'm using a optogenetic
approach to selectively turn off the
secondary motor cortical neurons which
we could do very actively as we confirm
with electric underreporting sit down -
you could then probe this this effect an
auditory cortex so this is your cycle
recording an auditory cortex during a
movement phase you turn up the light
within about 500 milliseconds that stops
the animal from moving but there's a
there's a period while the animal
continues to move and we can see that
the membrane potential of dynamics have
been restored to a wrestling state and
this is just a cumulative distribution
of these effects but every time we
turned on the light and silence them to
the ipsilateral auditory cortex return
to a rest like state higher than offset
can also probe this transition as well
they have all still bad but the auditory
cortex was in this dress like dynamical
state recover and recover
not completely but to a degree we would
have estimated based on the relative
vertical contribution not to this effect
so a quick review a Polish word buddy
there is a signature in the mouse
auditory cortex it movement at a
convulsive increase slight decrease in
resting membrane potential in a decrease
in membrane potential various both of
these are accompanied by a increased
auditory responsiveness
see the players at least locally
operated for Texas have imported
inhibitory pathways and involves in part
of our value depository cells act
postsynaptically and it made the driver
of this is a population of superficial
and deep hair cells and secondary motor
cortex that project to auditory cortex
and I should have although I didn't show
this year the true intersectional
tracing studies we're going to show the
these MT terminals or at two cells that
projected auditory cortex also targeted
deep brain structures associated with
movement so it's consistent with the
idea cells providing a corollary
discharge they know that can inform the
auditory cortex okay so a little bit
more to the model so we discussed today
this is a review by photography
colleagues a forward interaction since
speech as we've uncovered several times
sporting yeah it's a control system
not only manipulate the vocal tract a
general output generates auditory
feedback signal but through corollary
discharge mechanism and a turtle model
of both track uses information to serve
as a means of comparison of the actual
auditory to drive the controller system
adaptively the affective learning so why
is that they don't learn to vocalize and
in fact their vehicle record for certain
types of lot of where you got it
learning is someone in topper another
focus of our with our last work is the
song for your appearance II prevention
more about a minute but these are really
the consummate learners a few others
kind of a friendly models like to whales
and they culturally transmitted their
vocal patterns from one generation to
the next
it's common actually for the adult
doesn't engage in any kind of other
reads this is business you know straight
out full bore softly yeah even though
that juvenile fell asleep in this
incident this is really a transformative
experience for me there's a sucker out
of the feeder soft this is the encoding
song that the pupil of vocalization of
people makes partner tutoring yeah if
you record the adult song with that
people it will be an extremely good ash
to that tutor song even though it's
exposure to the tutor can be limited to
just a very early stage of development
in this assessment period for memorizing
the tutor song typically which adds
around 60 days after hatching and most
software species and then this is also
just to emphasize this is a very very
rapid base total experience necessary
for accurate copy maybe on the order of
a few hundred seconds so the tutor song
this was really before it as the animal
will undergo maybe 100,000 miles I was
singing the people will sing over you
know several thousand times a day for a
couple of months to generate something
that is a close copy of the tutor song
and in the zebra finches and some other
software species the song becomes how to
stable with the onset of sexual maturity
and the fact that stability is essential
for functioning as a communication
signal especially to females
she's but that stable pattern is
maintained is an auditory feedback I'll
come back to that a little bit later
circuitry is also very well mapped out
in some regards and particularly from
motor control and others simplify this
there's a promoter network that includes
this structure HBC group says the dorsum
in telencephalon the project's total
analog here Nazare which is in turn to
the both of respiratory planning and
brain stem motivations in person I think
that it's very rough analogy you can
think about HPC is kind of like broke
this region if there's a pilot operative
lesion that these furs can make your
contact calls and they call firstly well
that the cavities these border songs HPC
has a protection and cell type promoter
cell that projects the RA then it has
another cell type that projects into the
basal ganglia and there's bath way as
it's shown in completion but this
projection is a necessary production of
the production of adult song but it is
necessary for the feedback dependent
modulation of song implication of this
path waves by a critical role in
learning and finally there a sending
auditory projections through primary
secondary auditory regions in the
telencephalon
that projected a HDC and in fact in
different states auditory activity can
be recorded throughout this network
indicating the theorists before flow of
auditory information into the system and
in fact this is a simplified diagram
from the review I'm blank but the
long-standing impression has been that
most of the architecture so regions use
a lot of prohibitions HPC there's a
structure sitting right here
that that projection 2hdc but also
receives a small terminal projection
from HPC and in turn projects to reach
and say Michael fee and and others map
as part of an error correction circuit
that feeds through the drain dopamine
neurons and into this basal ganglia
structure though this area actually when
we started to look at this we thought
well the the dominant view was this is a
very sparse projection probably not
important to birdsong and because it
branched off of the pathway we thought
well maybe these are something
collateral of these cortical strangle
neurons these so-called
HPC s neurons we use triple labeling
techniques the different cell types so
retrograde tracing from already as
travel ash and they quickly revealed
that the cells that project into this
larger region or the same cell type
they're shown right here and a little
bit higher magnification here on the
right but we're talking or laughing
colors and in any of these cell cell
populations that all think build over
synaptically connected in some
interesting ways that I'll come back to
in a minute
um these these cells are also very
sparks they make up about 1% of the
total cell population HBC or maybe even
fewer than that and they tile HPC as far
as we can tell early uniformly let it a
fairly great business for one another so
much lower density than the other two
projection neuron types we're able to
adapt an intersectional genetic ablation
technique developed by this graduate
students in yang it uses a flex cast
base that we can introduce not
specifically into HPC but in the absence
of the creamer combinations this is not
legal and they need to the retrograde ly
transported pre virus to selectively
expressed past base and these
from HDC in the auditory system using
that design we were able to selectively
ablated these cells at early stages of
development I should say with these ad
vectors we use it simply takes about 20
to 30 days to provide our expression to
wrap up so the injections were made
between 30 and 40 days and agender
mashing and we think that full
expression is probably reached about day
60 the end of this sensitive period from
memorizing a Tudor sauna and well I mean
two o'clock that is the animals house
with the Tudor drought as possibly think
is likely that the auditory experience
of the Tudor was probably not so much
affected as a subsequent local copy
phases we can then race these birds up
to adulthood to match the similarity of
their songs their tutor and these birds
with a select mention that equation of
therapies HPC out-lap cells is what are
taught to treat cells do a very very
quick analysis and we're surviving cells
of this subtype t th BCG smells there
seems to be a steep drop-off but when
you get below certain complement of
these in your office learning is more or
less be well and I should explain these
metrics a little bit unrelated birds in
her Holyman typically score at about
this level about 35% so this we think is
a learning floor and normal copy levels
are around 80 to 90 percent just
inspecting some these undergrads they
give you a flavor for the behavior
here's the tutor song here's an intact
sibling there and here are two siblings
saying clutch male siblings that have
had this relation is left with ladies
HPC Avalanche cells and so I'll show
some elements of copper
so kinds of sauces to an aficionado are
renowned as an aversive the race when he
asked us to tutor altogether so it
really looks like they're not well at
all
and the this you know might be explained
simply that we're selectively plating
excel that's better than a promoter
Network yeah damaging motor control but
if we make similar lesions and adults we
don't see evidence of the motor even a
lot of time point suppose ablation of
these cells in the adult the sock
remains highly state one effect if
anything it seems to be a little bit
more stable than what birds will
normally produce and that then I mean
its water whether on this cell type is
important to ongoing maintenance of a
song and particularly feedback dependent
maintenance they saw as I mentioned
adults need permission to use auditory
feedback to maintain a stable vocal
signature and you can see that for
example by record this underground an
adult bird that bilaterally deafening it
through filter exposition and then
recording its song eight weeks later and
her changes both the spectral features
the song also the Tucker organization
that are consistent with the idea that
the bird needs an intact auditory
periphery to maintain that stable vocal
signature yeah in in ways paralleling
our own continued dependence on auditory
feedback for stable speech and a dolphin
in animals with the sonic the selective
ablation of these news that allows
ourselves I should say these except
we're not well the animals after the
observation adulthood so these are
already learn to sing effectively
deafening doesn't have us in fact the
SOG remains highly stable
suggesting that this projection that is
this projection from HTC Android
operating system is critical for a lot
of Tory feedback maintenance as well as
experience dependent
so this is something about circuitry
here we can go into rates less
preparation make identify identify pull
so recording so these neurons and then
stimulate these two major outflow tracts
the one that goes to our area sees HTC
are a axons or the ones that go for the
agency to them let's try it out we know
from previous studies of both of these
cell types have local axon laterals that
in fact connect these are a and X
predict themselves to each other
and we can see in the survey the
stimulation experiment that we could get
a very nice robust excitatory synaptic
current in these Appalachian giant cells
while stimulating this rhpc IRA outflow
tract but in contrast we simulated in
this corticospinal pathway we didn't
just detect any responses and this is
just one example that we did at
nighttime and it seems that these
Avalanche projecting cells are receiving
selective input from the promoter pool
projects to our aim is thought to be
carrying the promoter commands for
singing I think this is very consistent
with a corollary discharge mechanism and
the auditory coordinates the curve and
in fact through
Lee and others who recorded extra
psychic ability in this region in
capacitance between regions through the
auditory system which are reciprocally
interconnected with a flash and one can
see evidence of such corollary discharge
signal including localization related
activity that occurs before vocal onset
and persists following definitely I'll
just give you one one example or one
taste of how we're trying to explore
this and then these self records that a
challenge
Collective physiology because they're so
smart so we've used an intersectional
method to express GK I'll show you this
kind of experiment this is using this
slightly sure one photon microscope
developed by Mark Spencer and his
colleagues we can express GPM
in these headlines protect himself and
the report 30 miles of singing these are
very crude they actually be tenancy
professionally before saying look this
activity either appearing intact and
then after deafening you can see that
the profile that it's the elevation
activity before both will not set high
level during vocalization is similar
controls where we don't express you camp
you don't see evidence on a fluorescent
statement so we think this is this of
course the notion that these cells are
providing a motor related signal into
the auditory system I'll leave it at
that I think the next step obviously is
to understand what the computation is
downstream of HGC and particularly in
this region but these cells terminating
but in terms of their role in learning I
think that it's clear that they're
important folks that you've been all
auditory feedback amount of maintenance
so I have a few more minutes anything
we're doing so I just want to turn to
the other set of experiments that ask
what the controller system itself is
doing this built on some really
beautiful work run by Kofi and his
colleagues including really working that
Bell Labs dependability using recordings
from anatomically identified hdççra
cells and bridging commonly through us
to chef Cosentino and Michael show that
there was this ultra smart pattern
activated so if he doesn't practice
here's the sila graph from three
motifs in the rover needs to produce my
bird let's see if this inflection
so here's the extracellular recording
from that individual hdççra cell this is
how expanded times plc like the digits
by frequencies that occur during these
very very smart occurs and single cells
firing at one time the motif the
different cells fire at different types
of motif water mechanism involving and
change that are connected to HPC are
they stop where activity propagates and
falkland fashion through this network to
control song time and this is a very
very influential on it has a very
attractive idea to directly test this
might belong orders of postdoc with
Michael Pete used a miniature Peltier
device bilaterally cool HTC which would
produce a remarkable effect of the
uniformity stretching long tempo over a
multi scale system please equipped a
control saw instruction and photoshop do
it exactly match both the - time scales
to the longest time scales the actual
cooled version that was introduced when
the pub table is turned on full power
and we approach this we thought well
this is really amazing
I've had many conversations with Michael
and his group about this and I what I
was curious about is this an APNIC
architecture that you support that kind
of process and we we big post pic on my
group I used to and it should not be a
device similar to the was employed by
these group and we produced this this
observation that is one agency is
bilaterally fooled the soft stretches
and it stretches about 30% for every 10
degree Celsius 10 about 1.3 we thought
what we can go in and measure the
network in HPC and look at its
temperature dependency but this is
either going to be really really
exciting because all the other studies
and they're about 150 at one study have
the synaptic transmission in networks
for the dependents an order of magnitude
higher so we've got your special
temperature dependence analysis an ADC
or maybe maybe there's something else
going on here so the design of these
experiments in both words and astatine
brews mr. Sennett reporting is made from
an HP CRA cell and then we have to
dramatically activate it the outflow
tract connects hdççra
this is the lively evokes the synaptic
potential cool agency study what happens
to be on set delay and it return soon
and value that's done kind of a five to
six times greater than the behavioral
effect so that HP CR and TCR statuses so
a temperature dependence that dilates
about 150% for 10 degrees Celsius
question what's the apart of texture
that could explain that and so one thing
is that's not emphasized perhaps enough
is that the recurrent architecture in
the vertebrate brain is also president
songbird in the case of the song system
there's projection down of the vocal
respiratory planets and subscribe but
from a respiratory promoter complex in
the lateral Matala there's a bilateral
projection off to the thalamus that
feeds back both this laterally and
contralaterally to HBC and in fact this
is a critical linkage for helping
coordinate activity into and
particularly coordinating activities you
see they'll be simply cool
this system bilaterally at HPC working
laterally on a side that for making the
interest site of reporting and
stimulated on the contralateral side you
can measure the propagation time through
this networks of foreign synapse
loop and that temperature dependence
exactly now hop to the behavioral
so the law times there's an activity
propagating through this network for
about 16 milliseconds the 30 to 38
degrees Celsius
yeah with cooling stretch about 4
milliseconds to about 20 milliseconds
which is very very less to get real
effects just show up here so again the
HDC are the HTC RS and having that
network level that isn't brain wide
temperature dependence suggesting rather
than a local model that there is a
single fire chain it's a loop like
structure that passes out of the
forebrain into the brain static yeah
back up through HB see if we can invest
intimidation so you might contribute one
or two additional synapses so I'll
finish there this bit of size with a
fully endowed synaptic assorted
necklaces before Larry discharged in the
auditory cortex before an addition to
operate or connects that underlies
movement related modulation a lot of
work we're glad to do cumin and
analogous kind of brilliance making
today's informational promoter region
importers of singing and song pattern in
the auditory system
inflates the learning specific role and
in both cases were very interested in
knowing what the downstream consequences
of these productions are were actually
auditory feedback signals are
interacting with not a pretty feedback
signals
I'm just emphasizing if we did the work
tatars
a lot of southwestern I don't I see them
needing these a Black Studies and that
David Schneider and Hatter's Nelson have
done this work on Mouse auditory
cortical circuits investigating